[Musique]
bienvenue non pas sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire mais chez moi
confinement oblige nous consacrons deux
émissions à la à la seconde guerre
mondiale en effet celui mais nous
commémorons le 75e anniversaire de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie et ses
deux émissions
nous avons fait avec jean lopez le
directeur de la rédaction du magazine
guéret l'histoire grand historien
spécialisé dans la seconde guerre
mondiale on lui doit notamment la avec
olivier wieviorka la direction de des
livres formidable et de tom des mythes
de la seconde guerre mondiale qui était
paru chez peyrat et puis la plupart de
ses livres consacrés au front de l'est
font autorité
on va les énumérer au fur et à mesure de
cette émission puisque celle ci est
consacrée au front de l'est la
précédente c'était au front ouest jean
lopez
rebonjour un jour commençons par part
par le malade
la bataille entre l'allemagne nazie et
l'urss vous dites que c'est le théâtre
principal des opérations de cette
seconde guerre mondiale en tout cas
entre l'allemagne et les alliés
c'est c'est le théâtre principal des
opérations terrestres jusqu'en jusqu'au
début de 1944 c'est incontestable mais
il ya deux autres théâtres d'opérations
il y aller théâtre d'opérations aérien
dont il ne faudrait surtout pas
sous-estimer l'importance que le théâtre
d'opérations maritimes dont je vous dis
que je ferais la même remarque alors
commençons par l'opération barbarossa à
laquelle vous avez consacré un livre
absolument formidable qui vient de
sortir va donc est sorti l'été dernier
plus exactement
bill page barbarossa 1941 qui est paru
aux éditions passées composer un livre
coécrit avec la ccia autres mais oury
le est ce que hitler pense vraiment
qu'il peut occuper vaincre d'abord
occupée et colonisée le pays le plus
vaste et le plus peuplé d'europe ça
paraît une décision irrationnelle où il
le pense je pense que si elle pas penser
il ne se serait pas lancé dans cette
aventure
cette cette idée que l'avenir de
l'allemagne passe par l'établissement
d'un empire colonial à l'est sur le
modèle de l' empire colonial français et
britanniques qui lui se trouve outre-mer
lui il envoie un autre terre il voit
très bien coloniser les la russie au
moins jusqu'à l'oural
alors là aussi c'est ça sa pensée à hbo
a beaucoup fluctué
alors est ce que c est ce que c'est une
analyse rationnelle
non non le projet le projet est un
projet tout à fait hors norme hors
catégorie en europe au moment où ce
projet est conçu 1920 entre 20 et 25
plus personne en europe ne pense en
terme de destruction d'un état de
destruction d'une population ça n'existe
plus ça depuis au moins la sphère de la
fin de la guerre de trente ans on
n'utilise plus ce genre des catégories
les états sont en place ils ont des
gouvernement transitoire ou pas
transitoire mais on s'arrange
là on a fait un projet absolument
radicales destruction de l'union
soviétique
ça c'est l'anti bolchévisme d'hitler qui
est à l'heure mais aussi destruction de
la nation russe et de toute forme d'état
qui lui soit propre
ça c'est nouveau qui veuille détruire le
bolchévisme je pense qu'il n'était pas
le seul à y rêver dans l'europe d'après
en revanche refusé aux russes toute
forme d'état national ça c'est
radicalement
alors ils pensent y parvenir justement
en vertu d'un mythe qui est probablement
le mythe le plus meurtrier de l'histoire
qu'est le mythe du judéo bolchevisme
il fait partie parce qu'il n'est pas le
seul des gens qui pensent que en 1917 la
prise de pouvoir par le parti bolchévik
c'est la prise de pouvoir par des juifs
c'est la même chose pour lui la classe
dirigeante traditionnelle russe pénétrer
l'élément germanique comme il se doit
les fameux baron balle a été liquidée
soit fusillé par la tcheka soit forcé
les migrations ce peuple n'a plus ses
élites traditionnelles la nouvelle élite
entre guillemets qui s'est mise en place
c'est celle que évidemment staline des
tests pardon telle que celle qui perd
des pestes avant tout ce sont celles ce
sont les commissaires juifs
les bolchéviks juifs les trotsky les
îlots viège les kaganovitch et les
autres dont ils pensent qu'ils ont pris
le pouvoir en russie
il voit donc ils projettent l' espèce de
fantasme d'une masse de moujik abrutis
mené par des gens sans foi ni loi
bref un état qui va s'effondrer au
premier choc pour l'union soviétique est
un monstre
politiquement parlant et racialement
temps une campagne militaire a de fortes
chances pense-t-il
ces généraux le pensent aussi de
provoquer l'effondrement de ce régime de
même que le la défaite militaire dit-il
en 14-18 avait provoqué l'effondrement
des romanov donc il y croit il y croit
vraiment c'est quelque chose qui médite
c'est quelque chose qui a pu devenir
plus discret dans ses propos avec à
certains moments notamment après entre
1933 et 1939 mais c'est fondamentalement
là il a une espèce de visite
on l'avenir démographique économique
raciale de l'allemagne passe par la
conquête de la russie jusqu'à l'oural
alors l'opération barbarossa ce sont 10
millions de soldats qui vont s'affronter
pendant six mois puisque c'est le début
de l'invasion est normalement si ça
marchait ça s'arrêterait là puisque les
allemands par et vaincu aurait pris
moscou d'où ces six mois 10 millions
d'hommes qui s'affrontent sur un
territoire grand comme deux fois la
france
est ce que les allemands vous failli
gagner on se souvient qu'ils arrivent à
ahala au bout de la ligne de tramway de
moscou on se souvient de ces centaines
de milliers de soviétiques qui seront
des avions cloués au sol des
bombardements on se dit bon bah c'était
presque dans la poche
non non c'est d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs l'erreur que comme air france
alders le chef de l'état-major général
de l'armée de terre l'oqaj c'est
l'erreur qui commet en pensant que
finalement le russe est en plus mauvaise
attaque l'allemand en réalité après le
double en cire clément de base via sa
brillance qu'au mois d'octobre 1941 et
la reprise de l'offensive en le le 12
novembre
41 l'armée allemande n'est plus que
l'ombre d'elle-même
ces généraux ne cesse de faire remonter
des rapports extrêmement alarmant plus
de la moitié du matériel a disparu le
système logistique est en train de
s'effondrer littéralement les phases de
les fameuses équipements divers dont
beaucoup étaient fabriqués contrairement
à ce qu'on a prétendu ne peuvent pas
être acheminés sur le front tout
simplement parce qu'il a plu à ses
trains les conditions météo sont
mauvaises il ya plus à ses trains et
qu'on donne priorité au carburant et aux
munitions le soldat allemand est
littéralement au bout de son rouleau
il vient de il vient de
dot d'avaler 800 km à pied la plupart du
temps en combattant il a remporté les
plus fabuleuses victoire de la seconde
guerre mondiale il a fait une campagne
pratiquement sans faute mais il n'en
peut plus cette arme est encore une fois
c'est un fantôme et comme et comme on
projette que l'armée rouge est encore
empirer tas on pense que il suffit de
donner un dernier coup des pôles en
réalité nous le savons aujourd'hui les
allemands ne pouvait pas prendre moscou
c'était pas possible au moment où ils
ont voulu le prendre au moment où ils
ont voulu prendre parce que le staline à
fermiers les réserves ya trois ans mais
de reiser tout neuf qui sont planqués
dans les forêts qui attendent c'est geof
qui a pris en main la défense ils voient
bien que de l'autre côté salé le le le
système militaire est en train de tomber
en morceaux littéralement tout tout ce
qui lui revient le 30 novembre est là
dès le 1er décembre le 30 novembre déjà
parus téléphone installé dans dix ans
bah c'est maintenant c'est maintenant
qu'il faut me donner les trois ans mais
reste des trois armées de réserve parce
que c'est maintenant qu'on peut les
battre mais j'irai encore plus loin même
si par miracle il avait réussi à prendre
moscou quoi qu'est ce qui aura été gagné
est-ce que l'union soviétique et l'armée
rouge aurait cessé de lutter
certainement pas certainement pas ah
bien sûr ça aura été moralement un coup
très dur mais d'une part je ne suis pas
du tout persuadé que les allemands
veille les forces pour garder moscou
déjà parce que prendre moscou ça voulait
dire soit faire un siège comme un
legging grade mais ils n'ont pas assez
de forces pour encercler quand même
cette ville qui est deux fois et demi
plus grande que leningrad ou ça veut
dire s'engager dans une guerre urbaine
dont on a vu un stalingrad que c'est pas
le truc de l'armée allemande lé pas bâti
pour ça donc encore une fois même s'ils
jouent comme avait laissé avancer les
allemands jusque dans la capitale
il fallait la prendre une fois une fois
prises il fallait la tenir et même en
admettant qu'elle était prise et tenu
encore une fois ça ne probablement ça ne
provoquait pas la chute du régime
stalinien mais de toute façon je pense
qu'une seule analyse militaires nous
montre que
de l'eau début décembre 1941 ce n'est
plus à la portée de l'armée allemande
j'ai en dehors d' encore une fois
pendant la guerre froide et allemands
ont beau jeu de dire mais on y était on
voyait dans l'eau jumelles les coupoles
d'or du kremlin briller sous le soleil
mi temps puis c'est pas possible à
quarante kilomètres de voir les coupoles
nord les coupoles d'or du kremlin enfin
toujours est il que ces quelques avants
gardes qui arrive effectivement dans la
lointaine banlieue
elles peuvent aller plus loin elles sont
très vite repoussée alors vous l'avez
dit il de la sous-estimer le patriotisme
russe
il a sous-estimé le commandement de
l'armée rouge on va le voir on va parler
du maréchal joukov qu'elle vous avez
consacré un livre
il a probablement sous-estimé aussi la
solidité du régime communiste
mais surtout j'ai l'impression qu'il est
sous-estimé terriblement les capacités
de l'urss en matière d'armement ils vont
construire les chars des 34 parmi les
meilleurs de la seconde guerre mondiale
ils vont construire des avions de chasse
il ya une industrie lourde en union
soviétique qui va se révéler deux
premières mode force est au fond très
supérieur à l'industrie allemande alors
très supérieurs en qualité certainement
pas les produits allemands sont des
produits bien plus élaborées bien plus
sophistiqué c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
un de leurs défauts mais en quantité et
même en rapport qualité quantité la
l'industrie soviétique a réalisé un
exploit dont je pense qu'à peu près
personne au monde ne la croyais est
capable en 1939
c'est ce que pense c'est une vérité qui
est partagé à peu près par tous les
observateurs de l'époque les documents
ce sont à mon avis totalement univoque
là dessus néanmoins néanmoins c'est une
la prouesse industrielle que réalise
l'union soviétique
elle l'a pas extrêmement sert d'abord à
l'appel d'un abaissement épouvantable du
niveau de vie de ses citoyens qu'ils ne
peuvent continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions pas seulement par le
patriotisme mais aussi par la terreur la
police est partout les soldats sont
mobilisés ne pas aller à luzy
ça équivaut à une désertion du front
avec les conséquences que l'on sait il
ya donc une dureté extraordinaire du
régime
et moi je pense que la guerre que l'on
imposé les allemands c'était la seule
guerre que staline et lé système
soviétique était capable de mener parce
que l'industrialisation soviétique cet
aliment ce chaos
c'est un chaos c'est c'est le désordre
le plus permanent c'est l'improvisation
permanente ça ressemble aux conditions
de la guerre et c'est exactement là
dedans qu'elle va surpris que cette
cette industrie va se montrer capable de
produire là où personne ne l'attendait
il faudrait tout de même pas oublier que
si cette industrie russe soviétique
pardon est capable de donner des coups
de collier violent est d'obtenir un
certain nombre d'objectifs
elle peut le faire sur une durée limitée
si elle a pu le faire pendant tant
d'années jusqu'en 1945
c'est aussi parce que elle a reçu des
injections de technologie de matières
premières dont elle ne disposait pas de
procédés industriels venant des
américains et des britanniques
zhukov le reconnaîtra volontiers dans
ses mémoires et tous les soviétiques de
bonne foi aussi le reconnaîtrons bien
évidemment pendant la guerre froide le
régime ne le reconnaîtra plus c'est
normal en un affrontement idéologique
mais les livraisons américaine je parle
pas seulement de livraison militaires
sont venus combler ce que l'union
soviétique ne pouvait pas ou ne savaient
pas produire et lui apporter aussi un
certain nombre de choses qui lui font
défaut et vous donner un seul exemple à
des ans un des grands handicaps de
l'aviation soviétique c'est la faible
puissance de ses moteurs
ils ont du mal à produire des moulins
qui dépasse les 1000 chevaux ça tient à
des problèmes de construction mécanique
mais ça tient surtout à la difficulté la
capacité de la pétrochimie soviétique à
produire des essences à très haute adige
octane ou par litre de carburant par
litre de cylindrée vous pourrez tirer
beaucoup plus d'énergie et de puissance
qu avec de l'essence ordinaire ça c'est
les amis
ricains qui le ramène ils vont leur
livre est précisément ce truc dont ils
ont besoin autre exemple l'industrie
automobile soviétique est absolument
sous d'immenses yeux très handicapé le
produit des matériels qui date de
l'époque bo qui sont copiés sur les
modèles ford des années 20 les
américains ont alors fournir 400 milles
matériels parmi les plus modernes du
monde
car ce sont des camions non pas 4 4 mais
site sis les fameuses dodge qui sont
parfaitement adaptés aux conditions aux
conditions soviétique et qui vont
permettre à l'armée rouge de résoudre
enfin son problème de motorisation
des exemples comme ça on pourrait en
fournir beaucoup donc en conclusion
formidable au insoupçonnées de là mais
aussi un grand merci aux américains dans
ce domaine alors parlant de joe cole
vous lui avait consacré un livre avec
l'achat auprès memory jock of l'homme
qui a vaincu hitler chez perrin alors
c'est l'homme qui a vaincu hitler ou
c'est l'homme qui a sauvé staline
zhoukov ac c'est une question piège
évidemment il ya un petit peu
d'exagération dans ce titre il a pas il
n'est pas seul à avoir vaincu 8 faire
bien entendu c'est l'armée rouge c'est
11 millions de morts c'est le peuple
soviétique
c'est l'ensemble des alliés occidentaux
américains britanniques ou mieux encore
dizaines de milliers de pilotes anglo
saxons qui sont morts c'est grâce à la
marine aussi des anglo saxons que tout
ce petit monde est venu à bout d'hitler
s'était pas chose facile
j'ai dit que j'ai écrit que je coche
avaient avait battu hitler parce que je
pense que à l'ouest on n'a pas été on
n'a pas été juste à son égard de même
qu'à l'armée qu'à l'égard de l'armée
rouge au général on avait su on a
toujours vu que les défauts et dieu sait
qu'il y en avait dans cette armée rouge
mais on n'a jamais vu des qualités et
les produits de très bonne qualité
qu'elle a pu sortir parmi lesquels des
gens comme joue kof
roh kossowski wasilewski
malinowski kopniaeff tel bookeen
en réalité ils sont nombreux j'ai fait
sortir du coffre du lot parce qu'il est
le plus important pour les postes qu'il
a tenus et que dès 1941 et s'impose sur
le principal conseiller de ce qu'elle
est mais il n'est pas seul loin de là
alors je comme c'est quand même là où
c'est extraordinaire c'est que ce type
dans ce but dit qu'il écrivait à peine
le russe
il a fait très très peu d'études et il a
montré des facultés intellectuelles
absolument extraordinaire au point de
diriger des opérations militaires qui
vont appliquer deux à trois fois plus
d'hommes et de matériel qu'au même
moment on utilise sur le front de
l'ouest un goût eisenhower et le grand
commandant des armées alliées jeu coffre
c'est un autre une autre dimension
d'impression alors j'aurai juste revenir
sur la comparaison que vous avez fait
parce que c'est une comparaison qui
revient souvent
si on compare l'opération bague ration
en juin 44 et l'opération overlord en
juin 44 en normandie on effectivement on
a l'impression que du point de vue
terrestre la sphère soviétique est bien
plus importante
mais n'oubliez pas qu'au vers l'or
d'être avant tout une opération
aéronavale au terrestre et que ces trois
dimensions que maîtrise parfaitement les
anglo saxons en fonte l'opération la
plus compliquée de tous les temps
infiniment plus compliqué que que que
l'opération back ration ça il faut il
faut jamais le perdre de vue
je veux revenir ce jeu coffre zhukov
l'état est un homme qui vient du monde
un monde du monde paysan
c'est un type qui a fait trois années
d'école alimentaire c'est vrai que quand
ils quittent peut-être une quatrième
année on n'est pas tout à fait sûr il
sait il s'est hissé il sait lire
mais par exemple il a du mal à écrire
c'est ça sa première femme qui sera un
terrain ch'ti tutrice qui va qui va
l'aider à s'améliorer
et puis il ya cette chose qui est
commune à beaucoup des futurs maréchaux
soviétique et généraux soviétiques et je
crois qu'il aime qui est commune à
beaucoup de soviétiques de l'époque
c'est la passion d'apprendre ces gens
sont conscients du routard russe ils ont
vraiment la passion d'apprendre ce sont
des autodidactes des autres didacte
brillant les hommes qui travaillent avec
acharnement
zhukov c'était pas facile de servir sous
16h20 c'est un type qui exigeait
il avait une dureté terrible dans la de
la discipline il fallait que le service
soit impeccable la tenue des amis
déployables c'est un homme qui buvait
pas ne fumait pas je dirais pas qu'il
disait jamais de gros mots parce que
c'est pas vrai il était connu au
contraire pour son intempérance mais
c'est vrai que si on compare son bagage
de départ à celui des grands
aristocrates de l'armée russo allemande
il n'y a pas photo je joue cov n'aurait
jamais dû faire ce qu'il a fait si les
déterminants sociaux logique de l'époque
tsariste savait jouer avoue jouer en sa
défaveur
c'est évidemment le système bolchévique
qui lui a permis de grimper de s'imposer
et un staline alors on sait qu'il a fait
des erreurs considérables départ
notamment en ne voulant pas croire
jusqu'au dernier moment que hitler
allait l'attaquer
est-ce qu'il s'est révélé un bon chef
militaire est ce qu'il a joué ce rôle là
d'abord oui il me suivait il n'a pas été
un bon chef militaire il a commis trop
d'erreurs pour qu'on puisse lui décerner
ce titre
en revanche en revanche il a été un bon
chef de guerre car il a su comme
personne d'autre probablement en eux
reçu mobiliser le pays jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de sang est la dernière
goutte de sueur
on connaissait méthode je vais pas y
revenir ici mais j'insiste sur cette
différence
il n'est pas un grand chef militaire les
bêtises on pourrait parler jusqu'à
demain matin de ses erreurs que ce soit
barbarossa que ce soit l'encerclement de
kiev ce soir encore une fois l'erreur
sur la sur les attentions allemande de
mai 42 qui arrive qui amène au désastre
de kharkov
il a multiplié les bévues c'est
incontestable il a souvent été une gêne
mais pas seulement
alors comme khrouchtchev avec ruth chef
à prétendre au monde du 20ème congrès
qu'ils savent même pas lire une carte
évidemment cette absurde comme hitler
c'est un homme qui comprend contre 16
officiers du pas il comprend
parfaitement ce qu'on lui dit mais c'est
pas sûr domaine les opérations il est
sûre je le jour 1 les rapports de la
staf cas le staff gaëtan staff cas si
staline son petit état major personnel
tout
jours il est en rapport au téléphone ou
par télex avec les chefs de front avec
les représentants spéciaux de la staf
cas tous les jours
a part ça le reste du temps et la nuit
eh bien il va gérer l'effort de guerre
il a son petit carnet dans lequel il
note le nombre le nombre d'avions le
nombre de chars qui sont produits iman
la diplomatie il est absolument partout
j'écris quelque part avec l'achat dans
notre bouquin son barbarossa que l'union
soviétique a failli perdre la guerre à
cause de lui mais qu'il ne pouvait pas
la gagner sans lui
justement parce que tout le régime est
organisée autour de lui s'il avait connu
une défaillance
il n'a connu qu'une journée de
défaillance adieu l'union soviétique
certainement mais il a du bon il a tenu
bon il a fait il a fait preuve de
réelles qualités alors le travail ça ça
va être cette année des travailleurs
mais aussi de réelles qualités de bon
sens il a su écouter ils assurent
resserré il a su il a su écouter il n'a
pas toujours écoutés mais il a su
écouter joue cov et va signer ce qui est
parfois chape le vieux chapochnikov
avant notamment à koursk là où ils
voulaient attaquer les allemandes de
toujours attaquer staline maladie chez
lui quand je joue peu au fait vacciner
ce qui lui explique qu'il faut pas
attaquer mais qu'il faut laisser venir
et qu'il faut monter un piège là il le
comprend l'agent nobles valeurs de
staline c'est la première journée de
barbaros à 1
non non c'est le sait le sait le 29 le
29 juin après la prise de minsk
là il fait un éclat il arrive à l'état
major général il fait un éclat on dit
que joue kof est sortie en pleurs il
ils disent on a foutu en l'air il dit à
amicaux y amener à kaganovitch on a
foutu en l'air le l'héritage de lénine
et il disparaît y part à sa ville at
which evo et on n'entend plus parler de
lui pendant 24 heures
en réalité son secrétaire proscrite chef
c'est très exactement où il est mais là
il a un passage à vide il vient pas au
bureau ça n'est jamais arrivé ni avant
ni après il vient pas au bureau du
kremlin
il reste à sa datcha et là c'est molotov
terrorisée comme les autres qui prend
l'initiative de réunir ses collègues
beria malenkov taïga nos vies
et d'aller sans y être invité darif
d'aller accoucher vous à la ville à voir
ce calibre alors après on a beaucoup les
mémoires de mikoyan ne sont pas tout à
fait fiables sur ce plan là il dit que
staline est effrayé les voir venir
ça tient pas debout staline a été
prévenu de leur arrivée
très certainement il s'est même ce qu'on
va lui proposer
et il fait bonne figure ce que vient lui
proposer molotov c'est essentiel pour
comprendre la victoire soviétique que
vient lui proposer molotov c'est de
créer un super organisme de gestion de
la guerre le dk au comité de défense de
l'état et de répartir les grandes tâches
de la direction de la guerre entre les
hommes qui composent le cercle rapproché
de staline en les mettant à l'abri de
toute persécution
ça c'est une espèce de d'accord tacite
entre ces hommes on se partage des
fonctions
on va donner tout ce qu'on a dans le
ventre on va gagner la guerre mais on
stabilise la direction au moins le temps
de la guerre c'est notamment vrai de
molotov qui se sentait particulièrement
disgrâce en 3 41 41
donc là une stabilisation salines
accepte cette idée qu'il n'y a pas de
luis à le gecko à paris il accepte qu'il
endosse il dit au président de gai chaos
et à partir de là il n'aura plus jamais
de défaillance sur le front de l'est
jean lopez
on a longtemps dit que le grand
retournement avait été la bataille de
stalingrad
je crois que ça n'est pas le cas même si
c'est une terrible défaite pour l'armée
allemande
on a dit que c'était l'hiver on sait
qu'il n'était pas particulièrement froid
alors c'est quoi
et c'est quand le retournement il n'y a
pas de retournement il faut pas voir si
vous voulez la seconde guerre mondiale
comme un une route qui va tout droit et
puis tout à coup il ya un virage en
épingle à cheveux c'est pas comme ça
c'est le signe aux c'est une route
sinueuse sur laquelle la wehrmacht va
dévaler sans arrêt en s'usant
progressivement mieux ça pour
échec devant moscou c'est important
pourquoi parce que le plan stratégique
d'hitler est par terre il comptait sur
les richesses de l'union soviétique pour
pouvoir se retourner après contre les
anglo saxons en musclant sa marine et
son aviation pour c'est véritablement se
doter d'un empire colonial extraire le
pétrole l'acier le charbon soviétique et
avec ça à devenir une puissance mondiale
échec plus de plan stratégique en
réalité il n'y a pas de plan de
substitution
donc ça c'est très grave pour les
allemands mais ni en termes de matériel
et en termes de pertes humaines
c'est essentiel pour l'armée allemande
elle s'en remettra la preuve
la preuve c'est qu'en 1942 elle encore
capable d'avancer de 1000km d'arriver
jusqu'aux contreforts du caucase jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à devant grozny en
tchétchénie
jusqu à stalingrad et stalingrad
les allemands subissent une très lourde
défaite car la destruction d'un sixième
armée
les trois cent mille hommes qui
disparaissent d'un coup c'est un coup
dur mais encore une fois la messe n'est
pas dite
quelques mois plus tard en février mars
manstein à kharkov reprend l'initiative
et les allemands seront encore capable
en juillet 43 de monter une offensive
stratégique à course même si elle est de
bien moindre ampleur qu'en 41 42 donc si
vous voulez c'est une suite des fêtes
qui vont user une armée allemande qui
pourtant se modernise en même temps
l'armée allemande qui se présentent à
koursk elle est beaucoup plus redoutable
que celle de 41 elle a des matériels d
est tout à fait nouveau comme les chars
tigres les charpentes rc7 c'est une
armée redoutable encore
sauf qu'en face les progrès sont plus
rapides
donc je dire il n'y a pas de tournant si
vous voulez on peut distinguer un
tournant temporel churchill l'a fait
dans sa mémoire
c'est pour un moment de lui que vient
cette tradition c'est novembre 42
parce que ça coïncide avec la bataille
de la maille le débarquement des
américains torche en afrique du nord et
le de l'encerclement de la sixième armée
le début d'un cercle mans stalingrad
donc on a coutume de dire c'est en
novembre 42 que ça que le tournant se
fait pour les soviétiques s'est pas tout
à fait exact parce que il en prison
infligées ils ont reçu une des
est encore en février mars 43 pour eux
le vrai retournement ce serait la
bataille de koursk
c'est à dire le moment où ils ont
définitivement repris l'initiative la
hitler n'est plus capable d'entreprendre
quoi que ce soit à l'est on fait une
pause jean lopez on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
au delà de retour avec l'historien jean
lopez pour cette seconde émission
consacrée est la seconde guerre mondiale
jean lopez vous republier puisqu'il
était déjà paru les 100 derniers jours
d'hitler que vous avez sous titré
chronique de l'apocalypse chez perrin un
gros livre illustré on est ça commence
quand hitler quitte son qg sur le front
de l'ouest après l'échec de l'offensive
des ardennes et rentrer à berlin avec
dans son train spécial
il rentre à la chancellerie à ce moment
là les les frontières de l'allemagne ne
sont pas encore ou non pas encore été
franchie ni par les alliés à l'ouest ni
par les soviétiques à l'aise qu'ils sont
encore en pologne le pays et bombardé eu
toutes les toutes les nuits qu'est-ce
qui peut espérer à la hitler il ne s'est
pas encore enfermés dans le bunker ça
c'est les 10 derniers jours
mais à ce moment là qu'est ce qui peut
encore espérer il a 55 ans sa santé déjà
chancelante
où en est il ça accroche à à une analyse
géopolitique qui est celle de dire
l'alliance entre deux systèmes
antinomiques le système libéral
capitaliste et le système soviétique
d'économie planifiée ne sont pas faits
pour s'entendre
il va donc se bâtir un roman sur le
modèle de celui qui avait vécu frédéric
2 pendant la guerre de sept ans en se
disant je serai sauvé par la désunion de
mes adversaires
c'est sûr leitmotiv il ne cesse de le
répéter il est évident que militairement
il ya longtemps que la cause est
entendue se battre militairement n'a
plus aucun sens l'armée allemande ne
peut que subir de nouvelles défaites
je vous signale d'ailleurs que le tiers
de tous les moralement militaires de la
seconde guerre mondiale vont tomber
dans les trois premiers mois 2009 145 1
million de milles morts les quatre
premiers mois en comptant avril ça veut
dire concrètement que cette armée
allemande elle tient ses tranches et non
pas par le feu que par le sang de ses
hommes
on voit où elle est tombée on voit à
quel niveau elle et elle et
d'inefficacité aller tromper le système
militaire est en train de se désagréger
littéralement mais il continue il
continue parce que pour lui le dit
depuis le début
la reddition n'a jamais et ne sera
jamais une option ça n'est pas possible
de toute façon ils voient cet
affrontement comme une sorte de combat
des géants celui qui l'emportera sera
racialement le meilleur dans son dans
son panorama idéologique il ya cette
idée que si le peuple allemand l'a pas
se gagner cette guerre c'est qu'il
aimait racialement inférieurs à ses
valeurs
malheur au vaincu qu'il disparaisse on
est donc dans une semaine de schémas
d'apocalypse
il n'y a pas d'issue hier pas d'issue
militaire et il ya cet espoir qu'on
espoirs d'une désagrégation de la
coalition des adversaires sur les
journal de goebbels on est frappé global
se passe son temps à lire la presse
étrangère et à guetter les signes
justement de désagrégation une grève de
dockers à londres ça y est tout de suite
il envoie un coup de téléphone à la
chancellerie en disant ça y est ça y est
les anglais n'en peuvent plus bientôt
vous allez voir mon führer l'offensive
des ardennes leur a fait comprendre que
nous étions encore puissants bientôt ils
vont ils vont se retirer de la guerre ou
bien lorsqu'apparaissent ans en
yougoslavie tout surtout en grèce les
premiers signes d'affrontements entre
communistes et non communistes c'est
vrai la guerre civile grecque partir de
novembre 44
les communistes grecs et les
monarchistes soutenu par les anglais se
tirent dessus c'est le début d'une
guerre civile est abominable il y voit
les prodromes de ce que le führer
annonce c'est à dire cette coalition qui
se dénouent il a deux en avance pour ça
c'est trop tôt il n'a pas compris que si
cette coalition tient c'est précisément
parce qu'il est là lui la population
allemande va être sacrifié un temps au
cours de ses quatre mois décisif de 1900
les quatre premiers mois 2009 145 les et
maman aussi dit vous où elle va ouvrir
les yeux sur le caractère éminemment
criminel du régime nazi comme si elle ne
l'avait pas vu avant mais là elle s'en
aperçoit d'autant mieux que s'est tourné
contre l on fusille les déserteurs ou ce
que l'on prend pour des déserteurs ont
massacré ce qui reste d opposition on
avait déjà massacré l'opposition de
gauche ou d'extrême gauche mais il reste
l'opposition de droite et d'extrême
droite c'est elle qui va pâtir à ce
moment là le crime est gigantesque
y compris contre sa propre population si
en 1940 50 s'est pas rendu compte de la
nature du régime nazi on sait que
vraiment on voulait pas s'en rendre
compte
chez les allemands en fait les mots que
je pense que ce qui domine chez les
allemands c'est l' envie que ça s'arrête
à n'importe quel prix la vie quotidienne
devient très difficile notamment du fait
des bombardements alliés c'est ça qui
littéralement empoisonnent la vie des
allemands c'est les bombardements les
éloignements de population les
séparations entre les parents les
enfants les mais j'ai pas le sentiment
que l'abomination du régime apparaissent
encore à la majorité des gens moi j'en
veux pour preuve que quand ils les
marches de la mort les déportés qui qui
sont chassés les camps de concentration
par l'avancée de l'armée rouge etc ont
fait refluer vers le centre de
l'allemagne
j'en veux pour preuve que très souvent
s'il y en a un qui arrive à s'échapper
de ces malheureux en pyjama rayé ben il
est rattrapé par la population locale
qui peut parfois le battre à mort ou le
remettre à la gestapo dont je suis pas
sûr que tous les allemands aient compris
qu'ils aient tous envie que la guerre
s'arrête tout de suite demain matin oui
ça certainement parce que ils commencent
effectivement en baver notamment du fait
des bombardements
depuis un bon moment mais que la nature
criminelle du régime soit encore plus
évidente qu'avant ça l'est seulement
peut-être avec les pendaisons les
pendaisons soldats de la wehrmacht ça ça
ne s'est jamais vu dans les traditions
de l'armée allemande
et c'est vrai qu'il ya probablement
plusieurs milliers de pendaison qui qui
surviennent en première ligne mais il ya
même encore une partie la population qui
soutient 110 en bas c'est le prix à
payer pour empêcher la bête rouge de
pénétrer en allemagne ces 20 janvier que
les soviétiques
entre-temps d'allemagne les alliés ne
franchiront le rhin et que au moins de
mars et on al'impression alors à l'est
c'est terrible c'est la vengeance des
soviétiques ces viols pillages
destructions gratuites et on a
l'impression que les soldats allemands
se rendront plus facilement aux alliés
occidentaux que ce biais tic face aux
soviétiques
il n'est pas question de se rendre on ne
peut pas se rendre non alors ils sont
quand même bien obligé de se rendre en
juin l'opération bague ration il y en a
quand 200 milles qui ont levé les mains
un stalingrad aussi n'ont pas le choix
il est encerclé
mais chaque fois qu'on pourra en
essaiera de se soustraire les soldats
allemands sont persuadés que c'est la
mort qui les attend et les camp sibérien
je pense que alors d'une part c'est vrai
que la mortalité dans les camps
soviétiques est très élevée de l'ordre
du tiers un tiers des soldats allemands
ne rentreront pas de captivité mais je
pense aussi que les allemands projette
sur les soviétiques se les crimes qu eux
mêmes ont commis je vous rappelle que
sur les les les deux millions cela
presque 3 millions soldats soviétiques
capturé avant avril 42
elle a plus de deux millions deux cent
mille qui vont mourir dans des
conditions abominables dans des camps à
ciel ouvert avec des scènes de
cannibalisme atroce
parce qu'on ne les nourrit pas ils ont
été condamnés à mort ont littéralement
par la direction de la ferme arpents
donc je pense que les allemands savent
très bien ce que que la vengeance que le
soldat soviétique il va se venger parce
que d'une façon ils ont tous vu les
crimes terribles ont été commis en une
hausse symétrique
tous les combattants de l'est le savent
et l'ont vu et l'ont accepté et souvent
ayant participé maintenant que le soldat
soviétique rentrer en allemagne
ils savent que ça va être terrible il en
avait eu un avant goût de lire en
novembre 44 cas numéro 9
mais effectivement ça sera
particulièrement terrible
le commandement de l'armée rouge
n'arrivera pas à tenir ses hommes malgré
un certain nombre d'ordres qui ont été
données ils n'arriveront pas les tenir
et je dirais que c'est un des facteurs
qui empêchait de jouques of de prendre
berlin plutôt à un moment donné l'armé a
été au bord de se dissoudre dans une
orgie north j22 de viols de pillages de
meurtre de de talent cole c'est
apocalyptique ce qui se passe à l'est de
l'allemagne c'est pas par hasard si des
millions d'allemands plein hiver avec
des charrettes à chevaux des landaus
prennent la direction de l'ouest et
chaque fois que soldat allemand pourra
éviter la captivité à l'est face aux
soviétiques
il le fera le résultat en effet c'est
que quand les armées quand les
américains passent le rhin donc à partir
du 28 mars 1945 il ya plus vraiment de
résistance il ya quelques noeuds
quelques nids par ci par là mais il ya
partout des drapeaux blancs on se rend
par centaines de milliers c'est un
spectacle que l'armée rouge ne connaîtra
jamais la au moment où les américains
franchissent le rhin il reste un mois de
guerre à ce moment là avec l'allemagne
nazie
c'est vous l'avez dit vous avez employé
le mot d'accueil pokal ipsos 17 fait
être l'apocalypse les villes allemandes
sont en flammes sont bombardés assez
saman depuis plusieurs années ce ne sont
plus généralement que des tas de ruines
il ya des millions sans abri les gens
sont sur les routes
comment ce comment se ravitaillent t-il
même on a peine à imaginer quand on voit
les images de berlin à ce moment-là team
et ils vivent où ils sortent de quel
trou et comment se nourrit style c'est
le moment où on enrôle les adolescents
on pense même faire un bataillon féminin
c'est goebbels qui enrôle finalement ça
n'aura pas lieu
mais on voit bien que le pays est
absolument à bout de souffle on vit sur
les stocks
c'est seulement à partir de là de la
deuxième moitié 1944 que les allemands
commencent à ressentir les pénuries
jusque là ils ont relativement je dis
bien relativement été épargnées par
rapport aux pays aux pays occupés
l'armée allemande a suffisamment saisie
de leur école et de biens ou achetés à
vil prix des produits agricoles partout
en europe pour que les allemands ne ne
sont ne sent pas la fin avant avant
juillet août 1944 en 45 ans vit
uniquement sur des stocks et c'est vrai
que très très vite le spectre de la faim
commencent à rôder
mais je dirais que paradoxalement ils
auront plus fin dans l'immédiate après
guerre juste dans les trois mois qui
suivent la fin de la guerre que que en
février/mars offrit la bataille de
berlin à proprement parler commence le
16 avril les américains sont à 150 km il
ya cinq cent mille hommes je crois
qu'ils défendent la ville
l'objectif des soviétiques l'objectif
qu'on leur a assigné c'est le reich tag
pourquoi pas la chancellerie le rail
stock on le rappelle ne sert plus à rien
depuis qu'il a été incendié par les
nazis il ya belle lurette déjà non c'est
un mystère
j'ai jamais trouvé la moindre
explication saint mystère parce que le
reichstag c'est le symbole de la
démocratie parlementaire allemand cesse
c'est l'assemblée nationale allemande
elle a été détruite par les nazis en
1933 mais c'est une victime de la
lâcheté est une victime des nazis
ils ont incendié s'en souvient au mois
de février et mai 1933
pourquoi pourquoi là est ce que c'est
parce que c'est le monument le plus
célèbre de berlin sera peut être la
porte de brandenburg avec ses fameux
chevaux
ça aurait pu être la chancellerie du
reich non ça s'est porté sur le rail ce
stade tout de suite
et là je n'ai pas d'explication à vous
donner parce que je n'en je n'en ai
jamais trouvé qui se satisfaisante alors
la journée peut-être une
est-ce que ça n'est pas parce que les
soviétiques pensait comme tout le monde
que hitler s'enfuir elle berlin tout
simplement eco phu la chancellerie
seraient vides
c'est quand même dingue jusqu'à ce qu'il
soit resté jusqu'au dernier moment alors
que il ya eu plein de plein d'occasions
d'opportunités y compris dans les tous
derniers jours on vient le chercher en
avion souvient de ce moment voilà il
décide de rester de mourir là c'est
peut-être la raison pour lesquelles les
soviétiques ne visait pas la
chancellerie là ça explique pourquoi il
visait pas la chancellerie mais ça
n'explique pas pourquoi et visuel rights
act c'est vrai effectivement c'est vrai
que personne ne pense qu hitler va
rester c'est bon d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que ça donne du crédit c'est pour ça
que cette histoire de forteresse alpine
à laquelle croit les américains est là
elle a une
un choeur de vérité ta de plausibilité
tout au moins c'est que hitler il y à
l'endroit où il a le plus résider c'est
berchtesgaden
donc on pense ça semble logique il va
animer la dernière résistance dans les
alpes n'oubliez pas qu'il est autrichien
c'est un monde à un homme qui vient des
bandes alpin retour là bas
ces personnes n'a parié sur le fait
qu'il allait rester à berlin
et pourtant à la grande stupeur il
décide de rester en berlin et de mener
la dernière bataille
il se réfugie dans le bunker à partir du
20 avril un bunker qui a été construit
sous la chancellerie le 20 avril c'est
la date de son 56e anniversaire
vous avez vu j'imagine la chute le film
de 2h guiboles avec bruno ganz
composants à
adolf hitler absolument extraordinaire
imitant même son son accent est ce que
est ce que c'était un film d'un point de
vue historique puisque vous vous
connaissez très précisément ce qui s'est
passé au jour le jour pendant ces
derniers jours d'hitler est un film
historiquement juste oui ah oui c'est
remarquable c'est vraiment c'est une
leçon d'histoire
la performance de gang c'est absolument
éblouissante vraiment je les trouvais je
les trouvais remarquable oui c'est tout
tout tout est juste a été reconstitué
d'ailleurs je demande si le bleu le
conseiller le conseiller du réalisateur
on ne sait pas quelle offre un des
historiens les allemands les plus
pointues reçues cette question là non
c'est vraiment un très gros match c'est
vrai que cette histoire de bunkers et
est complètement folle qu il clair c'est
qu'il n'en sortira pas il sait que ici
ans ferme pour y mourir
ça s'est même s'il n'annonce pas tout de
suite c'est implicite c'est implicite il
ne se voit pas percé dès le hall et les
les allemands savent très bien en
fonction de la disposition d'aidés front
soviétique collier fo sud en kossowski
au nord et je coche dans l'axé central
ils savent très bien que la ville va
être encerclée comme ils n'ont plus
aucune domination aérienne
on pourra pas extraire le führer si la
ville est encerclée donc hitler est
prévenu il faut sortir avant que le
cercle soviétique se referme
si vous ne sortez plus c'est pour y
rester définitivement
et ça ils l'acceptent il n'y a pas
l'ombre d'un doute
il n'a jamais songé à partir tutto mois
après après le 16 à quel moment at il su
qu'il avait perdu la guerre votre avis
jol disait en 1942 hitler savait déjà
qu'il avait perdu la guerre mais en même
temps quand on voit le film bien giebel
et quand on connaît sa détermination sa
foi dans les armes secrètes v1 lv2 qui
auront pourtant pratiquement aucune
importance militaire qui vont coûter
énormément d'argent et qui ne
rapporteront rien sur le plan tactique
et stratégie
nick à quel moment est ce qu'il a
réalisé on le voit encore une fois dans
le film the google déplaçant des
divisions qui n'existe plus
y at il eu un seul moment il a pensé
pour ma ça y est j'ai perdu alors il le
dira d'emblée au caire la guerre est
perdue
il le dira il serait temps les les
propos de yodel qui sont souvent apporté
c'est vrai pour ces questions parce que
c'est yadel disent à quelques jours
avant d'être pendu à nuremberg et il dit
à la question d'un je pensais pas en
france est d'ailleurs qu'il entre au
delà ce moment là mais il ya personne
avant hitler qui a su que la guerre
était perdue et il le sait il le sait
après l'échec devant moscou et la
déclaration de guerre aux états unis
donc on peut situer d'après yodel à
janvier 42 le moment où hitler pense que
il a peu de chances de gagner la guerre
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il pense
qu'il a perdu depuis la gagner en fait
ce qu'a voulu dire y'a d'la mon avis est
que hitler comprend que barbarossa
échoué le régime soviétique est beaucoup
plus solide qu'il ne l'espérait l'armée
rouge est plus solide qu'il ne
l'espérait de l'espérer donc tout son
schéma on en finit en quelques semaines
à l'est on colonisent le pays
on extrait les matières premières ont
construit une arme et une marine et
l'aviation puissante et on mène une
guerre de dix ans pour la domination du
monde contre les anglo saxons tout
s'effondre ça il le sait mais néanmoins
il continue à penser qu'il peut arriver
à emporter une décision militaire avait
accès là j'ai pas d'autres explications
à donner que il comprend que son schéma
le plus optimiste ça c'est fini
mais en même temps c'est pas une raison
pour déposer les armes toute façon s'il
est un type qui d'entrée cet interdit
tout recul n'ya pas de pensée politique
chez hitler en dehors d'eux je ne me
rendrai jamais plus jamais novembre 1918
nous ne capitulerons jamais c'est écrit
en grandes lettres blanches à la
peinture sur tous les murs des villes
allemandes
il le répète sans arrêt pour de lui nous
ne recommencerons pas ce qui c'est
la honte de 2918 nous ne capitulerons
pas parce que nous n'avons rien à
espérer de nos adversaires
rien lui il a compris qu'il n'a rien à
espérer de ses adversaires je me demande
si son entourage l'a compris parce qu'il
ya des velléités chez yves mersch et
göring de de négocier avec les alliés
alors évidemment pas avec les
soviétiques mais avec les américains et
avec les anglais ils sont dans
l'illusion qu'on peut encore s'entendre
avec eux qu'on peut leur faire une place
qu'on peut ils sont alors là il plairait
bien plus de six coeurs
oui de ce point de vue là bien sûr y
meurt c'est incroyable qu'ils meurent et
göring puisse penser un seul instant que
les anglais les américains et discuté
avec les deux plus grands criminels les
plus recherchés de sur terre il a
discuté avec eux ils vont jusqu'à
marchande et des juifs
enfin c'est incroyable bien sûr sanary
n'arriveront jamais à rien goebbels lui
pensait qu'on peut être discutée que
staline
il est le seul c'est drôle parce que on
dirait qu'à la fin du régime
les vieilles option de départ de ces
hommes réapparaissent goering très
proches très proches du grand patronat
avec très introduit dans les milieux
mondains se retrouve un amour pour pour
les anglo saxons et goebbels qui lui fut
un homme à gauche un homme qui admirait
le bolchévisme dans les années 20 a
finalement c'est le dernier qui lui a
peut-être que c'est avec staline qu'il
faut discuter je parle de sa in extremis
en les 48 dernières heures de sa vie à
ce silence au journal il ya énormément
d'appréciation et le jeu du système
stalinien
c'est assez paradoxal et c'est très
ambigu chez goebbels
mais bien sûr mais ça n'empêche pas
quand même hitler de mener la danse
jusqu'au bout d' interdire qu'on se
rende d'interdire absolument à tout le
monde de se rendre et d'animer la
résistance jusqu'au bout ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il a décidé d'entrer y
ait une espèce de logique dans son
parcours qui peut nous paraître
démentent
mais il ya une logique ce qui pose
problème c'est comment se fait-il que
les allemands aient pu se battre si
longtemps la compagnie
longtemps dans cette danse et on ce
jusqu'au boutisme
c'est ce refus de ce jusqu'au boutisme
qui explique l'attentât du 20 juillet 44
lorsqu'il ya quand même un certain
nombre de fichiers allemands qui ont
gardé la tête sur les épaules et qui se
rendent compte que après le débarquement
allié en normandie
c'est fichu l'allemagne n'a plus l'ombre
d'une chance de gagner la guerre et que
c'est sans doute le moment de d'essayer
de faire quelque chose mais comme il
faut être présentable pour discuter avec
ses ennemis il ça passe par une
élimination d'hitler donc folle
stoltenberg et tout les hommes de la
résistance allemande auquel il faut
rendre un hommage parce que c'était
quand même courageux ont tenté ont tenté
cette option
cette option qui entre parenthèses et
toutes des hantises de staline c'est
staline craint vraiment qu'au dernier
moment il ya un retournement politique
en allemagne qui se débarrasse des nazis
et qu'une sorte de régime à la
hindenburg viendra discuter avec les
anglo saxons sur le dos de l'union
soviétique
ça c'est la ccc la grande peur c'est la
grande peur de staline et c'est quand
même très paradoxal de penser que hitler
attend la désunion entre l'est et
l'ouest mais ne comprend pas que c'est
sa seule survie qui est maintien
maintien l'union au fond s'il avait
voulu être cohérent et introduire la
zizanie entre ses adversaires
il aurait fallu qu'il disparaisse de lui
même qui se suicident beaucoup plus tôt
et laisser mettre en place pour
l'allemagne un régime beaucoup plus
présentable qui aurait pu discuter avec
les uns ou avec les autres
il ya une contradiction majeure au coeur
de la au coeur de l'europe dollars de la
mise en abyme théâtrale qui claire fed
de son pouvoir apporter de 40 15 on a
l'impression qu'il créerait est assez
mal renseigné sur 16
me et j'en veux pour preuve au fond j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a jamais fait
tellement confiance aux services de
renseignement ça n'a jamais beaucoup
intéressé
je crois qu'il n'a vu l'amiral canaris
ce qu'une seule fois en tête à tête
c'est quand même absolument incroyable
quand on sait d'ailleurs que les
américains eux-mêmes n'avaient pas de
services de renseignement ils vont créer
ils vont créer juste là pour l'occasion
on dit qu'au fond il ya que les anglais
et peut-être virus dieu aux 2,2 chacun
de leur pays à leur manière de vieille
tradition dans ce domaine les services
secrets ont ni cross c'est pas comme
nous nous les français on y croit
puis très récemment depuis qu'on a vu le
bureau des légendes mais avant ça on ne
le voyait là donc une aimable
plaisanterie dans leur antre consacré
que des films pastiche aux services de
renseignement mais le fait qu'hitler
diluviennes et crues pouces question
hitler c'est très bien quelles sont ses
armes ces armes c'est mentir à tout le
monde
garder le secret sa décision pour lui
même jusqu'au dernier moment et il sait
très bien que c'est en frappant au
dernier moment quand on l'attend pas et
là on n'attend pas que ça ça déjoue tous
les services secrets du monde et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec
staline le 22 juin 1941
c'est sa principale arme mais c'est vrai
qu'il n'a jamais montré beaucoup
d'intérêt pour les services de
renseignement il faut dire que les
services de renseignements allemands
n'ont pas particulièrement brillé dans
cette guerre non plus faute faute sont
peut-être de moyens faut peut-être aussi
une tradition aussi assuré que celle des
britanniques
alors ma dernière question jean lopez
c'est hitler si c'est il s'est suicidé
le 30 avril
s'ils s'étaient arrêtées après munich
comme l'espérait chamberlain après tout
à munich c'est sa dernière revendication
c'est les allemands des sudètes une
partie de la tchécoslovaquie
imaginons qu'ils s'arrêtent là on est le
30 septembre 1938
on est quelques jours avant la nuit de
cristal il n'y a pas encore eu la nuit
de cristal
qui est une date très importante qui va
qui va jouer dans la dans la détestation
que le régime nazi va inspirer notamment
aux anglais
messi s'était arrêté à munich est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
l'allemagne ne s'en souviendraient pas
comme comme ta grand homme d'état après
tout ça aurait été l'homme qui avait
reconstitué l'allemagne après le traité
de versailles sans tirer un seul coup de
fusil classement voilà c'était quand
même une sacrée prouesse il aurait été
le plus grand homme d'état de toute
l'histoire allemande plus grande
bismarck car il aurait achevé leur de
bismarck et à la différence de bismarck
qui a fait trois guerres pour assurer
l'unification allemande
il n'en aurait mené aucune pour arriver
à ses fins seulement le la manoeuvre le
chantage l'intimidation le mensonge
péché véniel quand on pense à la suite
auray auraient été ses armes
oui je pense qu'ils auraient vu s'il
avait fait un arrêt cardiaque en octobre
aujourd'hui on le sait les breurey
probablement comme le plus grand homme
d'état allemand avait quand même des
petits bémols on dirait sans doute que
on ne savait pas vraiment comment
fonctionner le reich il y avait eu des
camps de concentration mais là aussi il
y avait encore rien de rien de massif
mais on aurait quand même remarquer
qu'il avait transformé la vieille
tradition
étatique allemande en un tas de ruines
que l'économie allemande allait très mal
en réalité tout ça ce serait apparu mais
je pense que encore une fois oui il aura
été le plus grand le plus gros pot de
l'histoire allemande au lieu de vie en
devenir
il est aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
repoussoir absolu pour les génération
d'allemands d'après la guerre en
espérant que ça reste comme ça
merci jean lopez merci pour ces deux
émissions que vous nous avez consacré
sur la seconde guerre mondiale merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]